[Music]
in this video we shall talk about the
creatures of the dune universe called
the sand worms
or also known as the shy hulu in the
freeman language of their world and what
we know of the 2020 version of it
introduced in the 1965 novel sun worms
are
colossal worm-like creatures that live
in a desert planet called arrakis
the sun worms were also seen in the 1984
film the 2000 mini series dune
and the 2003 children of dune and will
also make a comeback
this year with a remake of the original
movie
these sunworms produce a drug called the
melange also known
liquidly as the spice which is highly
priced across the universe for its
medicinal
and mystical properties melange deposits
are found in the sun seas of arakis
where the sun worms live and hunt
and the substance is what drives the
entire plot of the movies games and
novels
so the sun worms were giant life forms
of the planet arrakis
it lived in the vast deserts and sand
dunes that stretch across the surface of
the planet
sun worms lived beneath the sun and is
as said
before they are the ones that produce
and guard the sources of the spice
melange
they are attracted to rhythmic
vibrations on the surface and they would
breach in pursuit of the origin of these
vibrations to defend their territory
of which they were very highly
protective of
therefore it was considered a very rare
thing to have seen one
and left to tell about it it was
extremely rare save for the mysterious
freeman
who achieved some kind of mastery over
the bees
so you might ask what is this planet
called arrakis let us start with
humankind having evolved on earth and
eventually gained the technology to
travel faster than light
they then expanded out to inhabit many
other worlds and explore
an even greater number they were
governed by an imperial government under
which the inhabited planets affiliated
together
this empire lasted for many millennia
and a remote desert planet called
arrakis
was discovered and colonized and the
sand trouts which are sun worms but an
earlier
stage of their life cycle were
introduced to this planet although the
old empire died off the remnants of
humanity and sun worms
continued to lift on in arrakis so let's
talk about their size
these huge creatures are thought to grow
up to 1 000 meters or 3
300 feet long and with a width of more
than 100 meters or 330 feet
but that is just legend behind these
beasts in the dune universe
although very rarely specimens of up to
450 meters long
was spotted by observers in the planet's
deep deserts
and just to make a comparison the blue
whale is only about seven percent the
length of a large sand worm
although the spice harvester factories
have reported that there was a sand worm
with a mouth of 120 meters or 400 feet
across
that is as big as the height of 2019
godzilla
and just the mouth so imagine the length
and what about their physiology so these
giant creatures were
like the earthworms of the earth but
thousands of times bigger
they ate sand and the inorganic and dry
components of the arrakis crust
it is also believed that they sifted the
sand plankton for nourishment
so these worms skin had thick rough and
orange scales it served as simple
function of armor
and was comprised of many individual
scales each a few feet in size
but that changes across the different
portrations of the sun worms in
the series the movies of 1984 and
even the recent trailer of the 2020 dune
so these scales overlapped and
interlocked to form an armor that
protected it against the internal sun
invasion
they also had strong flinty cinnamon
smell which was given off from the beast
especially the mouth
it is said that the sandworm could be
smelled before they were seen
another interesting thing about them is
that they generate a lot of static
electricity which results in dry
lightning when they come
out from the ground lastly a peculiar
thing about them is that water was fatal
to a sand worm even in small doses
water that entered the san juan's body
would act as a catalyst to accelerate
its metabolism
to the point that it became unstable and
its vital biological
functions failed this was a violent and
presumably painful death for the sun
worm although
the liquid that was given off from the
small sun worms
is called the water of life and used in
various rituals and also spice orgies
which is exactly what you think it is so
let's talk about the life cycle
these giants start out very humble as
they begin as microscopic forms called
the sand plankton
which are also consumed for nourishment
when they
are adults they then develop into a
larval form which are called
sand trouts and they're small and
leathery like kind of like leeches
and they term sand trouts which is also
their form when they were introduced
to the planet also called as water
steelers they steal out water
encapsulated
and trap it underground and with their
spice excretions it forms a pre-spiced
mars
which is explosive and when exposed to
the sun and open air
it becomes a refined form of spice this
process
kills a lot of sand droughts and a few
survivors hibernate for six years or so
and emerges sand worms that are three
meters or ten feet long
then they keep on growing so what is
their importance
the sun worms were essential as they are
the only reason for the creation of the
spice melange
and altogether on a macro scale the sun
worms had a very enormous impact on
humanity
to the planet's frame and population the
creature was a spiritual symbol of their
faith
and saw them as a physical embodiment of
the one god of their original
zen sunni religion within this the
freeman culture
the sun worm the had several additional
names notably the maker
and shahoolit which meant old man of the
desert or
old father eternity or grandfather of
the desert
however young sun worms were used by the
freeman for special ceremonies
for inducting new sayadinas or
irreverent mothers
and was a prime example of the sunworm's
essential cultural role and
also remember the spice orgies
so where did they come from although it
is widely stated that the sun worms were
a native life-form of the planet arrakis
and yes
it lived in the vast deserts and sand
dunes that stretch across the surface of
the planet
it is however canonically suggested that
the sun worms
were an introduced species that caused
the certification of arrakis
in children of due 1976 letter ii
explains to his twin sister ghanima
that the sand trouts were introduced
from some other place
arakis was a wet planet before and these
creatures proliferated beyond the
capability of the existing ecosystem to
deal with them
sand trouts insisted they available free
water and made iraqis a desert planet
and they did it to survive
in a planet sufficiently dry they could
move on to their sand worm faces
so what about fighting a sun worm spice
let's start with spice it has an
important role in travel and cultural
development as it is vital for space
travel by enabling navigators
to safely guide spaceships safely
through the warp space
so outsiders of the planet arakas would
constantly collect the item
but at the same time this precious
resource is guarded heavily by the giant
sun worms
and many expeditions would end
disastrously they are attracted to
rhythmic vibrations on the surface and
as i said before would come out of the
surface and attack the source
this was an effort to defend their
territory of which they were very highly
protective of
their scales were impenetrable to small
and medium weaponry but if the scales
are removed the softer skin
which is very sensitive could be harm
and by that it could drive the worm away
on another note the local freeman
natives of arrakis
by using thumpers and hooks have learned
how to
ride these bees above ground anyway
that's all we have about the sun worms
and i know there is much much more
so share your favorite parts of these
shyhuluts in the comment section below
do leave a thumbs up for support and
also check out our mindq teespring store
for awesome merchandise
so subscribe if you haven't and most
definitely hit that notification bell
till next time